Bonjour à tous, bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo.
Aujourd'hui, petit changement de décor
puisqu'on est dans ma cuisine
et qu'on va essayer de répondre à cette question
absolument essentielle qui est:
Pourquoi est-ce que le Pastis devient opaque
quant on l'allonge avec de l'eau ?
♪ [Générique] ♪
Alors le phénomène dont on va parler aujourd'hui,
je pense que vous avez déjà tous pu constater,
si vous prenez du pastis pur,
tel qu'il sort de la bouteille,
il est transparent.
Alors certes il est coloré,
mais vous pouvez quand même parfaitement voir à travers.
Par contre, une fois que vous l'allongez avec de l'eau,
il se trouble et il devient opaque.
Alors ce phénomène il est un petit peu contre-intuitif
puisque on mélange deux liquides qui sont parfaitement transparents,
donc on s'attendrait à ce que le résultat le soit aussi.
Alors pour comprendre ce qu'il se passe,
il faut s'intéresser à la composition du pastis.
Le pastis, quand il est pur, est fait d'environ 50% d'alcool,
et de 50% d'eau.
Alors je vous rassure, il n'y a pas que ça,
sinon, ce ne serait pas du pastis, ce serait de la vodka.
Oui parce que pour ceux qui ne le sauraient pas,
c'est scientifiquement prouvé,
la vodka, quelle que soit la marque,
c'est juste un mélange pur d'alcool et d'eau :
il n'y a absolument rien d'autre.
Alors que non, dans le pastis,
il y a quelques pouillèmes de trucs qui font le bon goût.
Et il y a notamment,
un arôme qu'on appelle l'anéthole.
Alors l'anéthole, c'est une huile essentielle qui est extraite de l'anis.
Et donc c'est cette huile essentielle
qui donne au pastis son goût caractéristique
et d'ailleurs qu'on retrouve chez tous ses cousins du bassin méditerranéen
comme l'ouzo en Grèce,
le raki en Turquie,
ou la sambuca en Italie.
Ce qui est important pour la question qu'on se pose aujourd'hui,
c'est le fait que l'anéthole, c'est une huile essentielle.
Et je pense que vous le savez,
l'huile et l'eau, elles ne s'aiment pas beaucoup.
J'en veux pour preuve le fait que
si vous essayez de mélanger de l'huile et de l'eau dans un verre,
elles se séparent.
Une des raisons pour ça,
c'est le fait que l'huile est plus légère que l'eau.
Mais en fait, c'est pas la raison fondamentale.
Par exemple, l'alcool c'est aussi léger que l'huile
et pourtant si vous prenez une bouteille de vodka,
vous ne voyez pas l'alcool qui surnage au-dessus de l'eau.
Non, la raison pour laquelle on a ce phénomène de séparation,
c'est tout simplement que l'eau et l'huile
ne peuvent pas se mélanger.
On dit qu'elles ne sont pas miscibles.
A côté de ça, l'eau et l'alcool, eux, sont miscibles,
et d'ailleurs, l'huile et l'alcool aussi sont miscibles.
Je vous ai dit, l'anéthole, c'est une huile essentielle,
donc comme toutes les huiles, elle accepte de se mélanger dans l'alcool,
mais elle refuse de se mélanger avec l'eau.
Alors qu'est-ce qui se passe pour l'anéthole lorsqu'elle est dans le pastis ?
Et bien dans le pastis pur,
il y a, je vous ai dit, à peu près 50% d'alcool et 50% d'eau.
Et bien, pour l'anéthole, ça va.
Ca fait suffisamment d'alcool pour qu'elle accepte de se laisser disperser
et donc les molécules d'anéthole sont parfaitement diluées dans le mélange.
Alors maintenant, qu'est-ce qui se passe
quand on allonge le pastis ?
Et bien, vous ajoutez de l'eau
et donc vous allez changer les proportions du mélange,
ce ne sera plus 50-50,
mais ce sera peut-être 80% d'eau et seulement 20% d'alcool.
Et là, l'anéthole, elle n'est plus du tout contente,
et elle refuse de se mélanger.
Et que font les molécules d'anéthole pour éviter de se laisser mélanger ?
Et bien elles décident de se regrouper entre elles
et de former des petites gouttelettes d'huile
qui sont dispersées dans le mélange
et qui forment ce qu'on appelle un émulsion.
et c'est ça qui donne au pastis allongé son aspect laiteux.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Pour comprendre physiquement ce qu'il se passe,
il faut faire appel à un phénomène qu'on appelle la diffusion de Mie.
Je pense que vous savez que la lumière est une onde,
et donc elle possède une longueur d'onde.
Qui va d'à peu près 400 nm pour le bleu jusqu'à 800 nm pour le rouge.
Et quand une onde lumineuse rencontre un objet
qui fait une taille à peu près du même ordre de grandeur que sa longueur d'onde,
elle se trouve renvoyée dans toutes les directions.
On dit qu'elle est diffusée.
Et donc qu'est-ce qui se passe dans notre cas ?
Bah les gouttelettes d'anéthole qui sont dispersées dans le pastis allongé,
elles font environ quelques microns de diamètre.
Et donc quand la lumière physique rencontre ces gouttelettes,
elle se trouve diffusée dans toutes les directions
et c'est ça qui provoque l'aspect laiteux du pastis.
D'ailleurs, quand je parle d'aspect laiteux, c'est pas innocent
parce que la raison pour laquelle le lait est opaque et blanc,
ben en fait, c'est exactement la même.
Le lait, c'est une émulsion de petites gouttelettes de graisse dans de l'eau
et donc c'est à cause de la diffusion de Mie sur ces gouttelettes
que le lait est blanc et opaque.
Et d'ailleurs, c'est exactement la même chose qui se passe avec les nuages,
sauf que cette fois, c'est des petites gouttelettes d'eau qui sont dispersées dans l'air.
Maintenant, je voudrais vous montrer un petit phénomène amusant.
Si vous prenez du liquide vaisselle et que vous vous amusez à l'ajouter à votre pastis allongé,
En touillant un petit peu, vous allez vous rendre compte que le pastis redevient transparent.
Alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Ben pour le comprendre, il faut revenir au cas au mélange simple d'huile et d'eau.
Si je prends mon mélange d'huile et d'eau de tout à l'heure
et que je m'amuse à rajouter du liquide vaisselle,
en touillant un peu vigoureusement,
je me rends compte que j'arrive
dans une certaine mesure à mélanger mon huile et mon eau.
Alors cette petite expérience, elle nous montre que le liquide vaisselle
permet de réduire un petit peu la tension entre l'huile et l'eau.
C'est-à-dire qu'il les rend un petit peu plus compatibles
et qu'on peut, dans une certaine mesure, les mélanger.
Alors maintenant, si on revient sur le cas du pastis allongé,
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Quand j'ajoute le produit vaisselle,
j'améliore un tout petit peu la compatibilité entre l'anéthole et l'eau
et donc même dans mon mélange allongé,
l'anéthole accepte finalement de se laisser disperser dans le mélange
les gouttelettes d'huile se cassent
et donc la diffusion disparaît et la lumière peut à nouveau passer à travers le mélange.
Et c'est pour ça que le mélange redevient transparent.
Alors maintenant, évidemment, il est imbuvable.
Maintenant, vous pouvez vous rendre au bar PMU du coin
et faire la version "tour de magie" de l'expérience.
Vous mettez discrètement un peu de produit vaisselle au bout du doigt
et puis vous allez touiller le pastis des gens pour le faire redevenir transparent.
Effet garanti !
Enfin au moins au début parce qu'après
je vous conseille de courir avant qu'ils le goutent.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo !
Si elle vous a plu, vous pouvez m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne en la partageant.
Vous pouvez également vous abonner, me retrouver sur facebook, sur twitter
et sur mon blog qui s'appelle science étonnante.
A bientôt !
Bon, je vais peut-être pouvoir le boire maintenant !